hello and welcome to this video playing
check off I am sure have no name okay
probably an Enzo and install the vast
majority of games um they play the
diesel and not the Queens gambit
declined even though that really got
into into fashion recently again with d5
let's see what my opponent is doing here
ok Knight f3 ok well the main movie c5
but d6 also is a valid valid choice this
looks a lot like I'm Zurich variation
now which is my line ok I'm going to
keep the tension here with Bishop to e2
ok wait yeah okay let's take I would
really like to take with the pawn if it
if he captures ok so that's not relevant
anymore this won't be six interesting
okay let's try it like that
trying to keep the tension and let's see
how black is intending to resolve that
okay can maybe take g4 takes takes d5 or
something like that i'm not sure this
one okay okay so I'm I'm keeping this
closed why not
okay hmm yeah f4 is a move I would like
to play but that Queen III check is
irritating yeah maybe this is this first
he definitely does not want to play for
that which is to make a week porn now
but well yeah i form a BF what takes
Luke Chisolm that's not completely
ridiculous
I would like to play a vortex and
context but i think i think i can also
wait if i go before he has a possible b5
where evidence that's probably not so
dangerous i think i can i can even also
play on the queenside and get the space
advantage going here before he goes be
five or anything like that but maybe he
can take and play play be 5 i'm not
saying it's totally impossible who
doesn't ok
I should have played f3m oh so he's
totally content with the with the worst
position Quinn side is closed and I'm
clearly better on the Kings side as I
get in half form I just have to prepare
it a little bit but now I'm ready f3 was
preventing you form and no f4 is coming
next for you might have shipped you form
I don't understand anything here what is
the deal
is it have form good already there's
only the Bishop g4 business but I have
twin be one for example after a form
that should be pretty and I am his plea
does that should be very nice long term
e for as weekend I will probably get in
g4 at a later stage yeah queen bee one
knock Renee one probably name one
threatening to take up 64 it's already
difficult for him
yeah it probably has to play Bishop f5
and that's not a move your love to play
even simple Bishop takes f6 is stronger
than okay six is collapsing change
yourself but I have a ch3
can I give g5 is stronger actually okay
it's kind of it's a moot point okay so
Knight f6 Korean f6 Bishop f5 should win
or is there is there something better
it's let's check okay I'll take that mmm
I didn't calculate that should i have
calculated and no it's it's double check
one check check
you for check Bishop before that's made
right the step program made check maybe
not I don't know that's made my queen g4
is made in one actually check me okay
now a couple of of surprising decisions
here by black um yeah this is I think
still okay for him he should I was
thinking maybe play with some kind of d5
try to get some foothold in the center
this was surprised I mean after d5 this
looks like a long-term advantage there's
a common I think misconception that
closed positions somewhat bad for poor
bishops for the bishop pads wrong the
bishop is also not so bad in a closed
position the the main thing is the
closed position still has to be fluid in
terms of pawn structure like here I can
actually alter the pawn structure like
with f4 and advanced or be four and so
on the problem is rigidness if the pawn
structure becomes very fixed rigid and
immobile and then the night's get better
and it's not like his nights are better
than my bishop see in this position
absolutely not okay some this f3 was
also an option preventing you for birdie
for it's never really great get this and
I was I was just taking the space him
and I think this is this is just wrong
closing it up there on the closing it
down both probably right yeah 3 I was
just taking time fo already was possible
it I wanted to prepare it and jab this
is not a good position and after you for
I think it's it's more or less over I
can also tell already take on f6
the this is strategically too bad if all
is bad and I get this get this the
bishop is fantastic and I get this Jeep
won't play the engine is also agreeing I
can basically also win win stuff I'm
Bishop f6 I can win material already I
was so I was so enthusiastic about the
strategy I didn't see that I can win a
piece yeah okay Ross probably check
convincing enough Channy Channy my queen
h7 is already made I didn't see it I was
the maid that as so imagine he was this
one check checkmate okay yeah way one
mate is enough okay thanks for watching